heidi you recently posted a throwback to
your first victoria secret show so what
do you remember about or do you remember
about it because it's gotta be chaotic
well i mean i should have won matching
set when i was rehearsing at home
i'm saying i'm thinking i mean yeah look
i put the carpet to the side this was a
railroad apartment that i had in new
york and
i just wanted to see what it looks like
when i walk because also at that time we
didn't film
ourselves as much as we do now with our
friends so i just wanted to see what it
looks like i didn't want to be on one of
the biggest runways
ever for me and you know not know what
it looks like so i walked in my heels up
and down that railroad
apartment to just you know until i got
used to you know
it's like rehearsing like we do with
music like exactly
yeah absolutely did you ever rehearse do
you rehearse or do anything like that um
i i used to rehearse a lot i used to
watch a lot of like
heidi's videos naomi campbell you came
out of my womb with heels on
no because like it was never something
that my family was into
or you know like yeah fashion modeling
anything so when i realized that it was
an opportunity for me i was like
okay anything you're going to do in life
you got to do it well so you got to
study you got to practice
people don't realize how hard is i went
to one fashion thing and it was amazing
because i love all those colors by the
way
um but it was it was amazing because
this this girl i mean
she was they had they dress you so fast
yeah oh my gosh and it's like somebody
did not said her like gladiators
yes they ripped the thing off
my quick change like literally so
nervous yeah and they just like didn't
care they were like
they're calling you yeah they were
already like waiting
but you have to trust those people a lot
because this girl came out in like
a gladiator type tie and they didn't do
it tight enough
and they fell and caught in her heel and
she fell
in front and i was like oh my gosh like
and that wasn't her it was just somebody
you know they were going so fast and i
was like that's these are gladiators i'm
like that's
hard yep i'm still here just waiting for
you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help